la maison familiale de gargilesse les
deux filles de pierre jamet côte à côte
l'aîné marie claire et de passage cette
année ses apparitions pendant le
festival se font plutôt rares
je préfère venir quand le village est
calme que je peux me promener
tranquillement et profiter de la maison
et travailler marbre dans l'atelier pour
me rappeler tous mes souvenirs d'enfance
la voici marie-claire jamais filmé à
gargilesse au début des années 70 en
compagnie de son mari
non parce que quand je venais passer mes
vacances ici à de longues années nous
jouions avec mon père aux fêtes du 15
août
et puis ensuite mon père organise ce
festival je suis venu jouer au départ du
festival il ya trois ans je crois 4
à cette époque son père vient de fonder
l'académie de harpe et le festival d'été
pierre jamet était très fière de sa
fille
la grande réussite de votre école c'est
votre fille bien sûr c'est le plus beau
fleuron des plus beaux fleurons mon
école
elle était fille celle de la tf donne
des concerts dans le monde entier avec
son arme dans des tailles grand flûtiste
comme des récitals un futur c'est une
fierté pour moi bien si c'est grâce à
lui
d'ailleurs parce qu'il m'a inculqué
l'amour de l'amour de la musique et
g
disons que j'ai suivi un petit peu ses
traces en faisant aussi un quintet et
après j'ai été j'ai beaucoup de musique
contemporaine avec pierre boulez
il était très fier que je continue dans
son ombre mais encore plus plus
contemporain voilà donc il était très
fier de ça je pense quarante trois ans
après marie claire jamais n'a rien
oublié
la fille du célèbre artiste joue encore
deux à trois heures par jour
dimanche elle donnera un grand concert à
gargilesse avec la même énergie
d'autrefois